PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today what I'd
like to do is work
on using Riemann sums to
approximate definite integrals.
So, what we're
going to do first is
I'm going to let you
work on the problem.
So, let me state the problem.
I'll give you a little
time to work on it.
And then I'll come back.
So the problem is the following.
We want to use four
subintervals and left endpoints
to approximate the
following definite integral:
the integral from minus 1 to
3 of the function x cubed.
And I've drawn a rough
sketch of what x cubed,
y equals x cubed looks
like to help you out
as the starting point.
So why don't you use the four
subintervals and left endpoints
to approximate the
definite integral, then
I'll come back and
show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
So what we want to
do, again, is use
Riemann sums to approximate
this definite integral.
And I've given you
the specifications
of four subintervals
and left endpoints.
So I'm going to
draw what these four
subintervals and
their left endpoints
are going to give
us on the graph.
Then we're going to calculate
what the actual value is
of this estimate.
And then I'll show you
a way you can write it
in some different notation.
So let me actually
find some blue chalk.
Excuse me.
So, using blue chalk
I'm going to show you
where the four subintervals
and the left endpoints.
So it's minus 1 to 3,
so I've conveniently
done it so we have
every unit length is
one of the subintervals.
They're all unit length.
And if I want left endpoints,
then my rectangle's heights,
if you remember, are going to
be the output at the left side
of the interval.
So I'm going to designate
the left interval as output.
And what do we have here?
I'm going to now draw
rectangles of those, using those
with the one side on
x-axis and one side
at the height of the
left endpoint output.
So there's one rectangle.
Oh, I almost did
something wrong here.
This left endpoint's
rectangle has no height.
Because the left
endpoint's value is 0.
The output is 0.
There's another rectangle.
And there's the last rectangle.
So, to designate
everything carefully,
I will call this value y_0,
the output value here y_0.
This value will be y_1.
The output value
here will be y_2.
And to show exactly what
do I mean by output value,
here I have enough room
to write the height
is really what it is, is y_3.
So y_0, y_1, y_2 and y_3
designate the heights
of these four rectangles.
And the length of each
rectangle, if you remember,
is really what we
designate as delta x.
So this right here is delta x.
And in this case delta x
is each time equal to 1.
So, remember, formally,
what we want to do
is, if we want to find
this definite integral,
we want to find the area under
the curve between the x-axis
and the function x cubed.
And remember this
is signed area.
So anything below the
x-axis has a negative sign
associated to it.
Anything above the x-axis has a
positive sign associated to it.
So, when I'm trying
to determine this,
when I'm trying
to do an estimate,
I'm finding the areas
of these rectangles.
So my first approximation
that I've given here,
is we want the four subintervals
and the left endpoints.
What we really need
is this delta x,
which is the base,
times the height, which
is y_0, 1, 2 and 3, of
each of these rectangles.
So, to write it
carefully-- well I
guess this won't be the most
careful way we write it--
but I have the base, which
is delta x in each case,
times y_0 plus y_1
plus y_2 plus y_3.
And the only thing I
have to be careful of
is that the area
of the rectangle
here will be negative.
But how do I pick that up?
I pick that up because this
y_0 value, as an actual output,
is negative.
So that actually will be
picked up automatically
by the value of the
output on the function.
So let's evaluate
these things. y_0
should be the value of the
function at x equal negative 1.
When x is negative 1-- the
function, remember, is x cubed,
so I get negative 1 cubed,
which is just negative 1.
So delta x is 1.
y_0 is negative 1.
y_1 is the value the
function at x equals 0,
because my left endpoints
are minus 1, 0, 1 and 2.
So the second one
is 0 is the input.
At x equals 0 I
get 0 as an output.
The y_2 is going to be
this third left endpoint.
That's at x equal 1.
1 cubed is 1.
So I get a 1 there.
And then, the third left
endpoint, I had minus 1,
0, 1, 2.
So the third left endpoint is 2.
2 cubed is 8.
And so y_3 is 8.
Hopefully the subscripts
here didn't confuse you
because I actually was very
close to having the subscripts
represent the x-value.
But that's not in fact what
the subscripts are doing.
The subscripts are
just representing what
interval we are looking at.
So the four intervals are
designated by 0, 1, 2 and 3.
So I get, when I put this all
together I get 1 times-- well,
minus 1 plus 1 is 0-- 1 times 8.
So I get 8.
And if I wanted to
look at the picture,
how is that represented?
Well this rectangle has
base 1 and height 8.
So that has area 8.
This rectangle is
actually a square.
It has base 1, height 1.
And this one is also a square.
But because it's below,
it has a minus sign
associated to it, when I think
about it in terms of area.
So I get minus 1 plus 1 plus 8.
And that's where
the 8 comes from.
Now if I wanted to write this
in terms of a Riemann sum,
you see them sometimes
written in this way.
You can think about it in
a formal sum in this way.
You've probably seen this in the
lecture videos more like this.
The sum from i equals 0 to
3 of f of x sub i delta x.
And now, in this
case, we could even
be more deliberate
if we wanted to.
And we could let x sub i be
designated by some value.
We could say,
starting at negative 1
and adding some
number to it each time
based on the interval.
But this is sort
of the easiest way
to write out what
we're interested in.
And then the x sub i's are going
to be designated separately.
We can write x sub 0 is equal to
minus 1, x sub 1 is equal to 0,
x sub 2 is equal to-- sorry, not
minus 1-- is equal to plus 1.
And x sub 3 is equal to 2.
So in that case, that's
what we would get there.
And we could write
it in that way
and then get the same values.
So I think I will stop there.